we very much later
died very stupidly left the street
an empty city there were 15000 but I don’t know at least
thousands were left only in
Vnukovo we’ll fill up the race in this library
last time we sat in the basement it’s like
putting
such fruits were all just
bought a refrigerator
to leave to leave
well here  only hits here, here, the
glass, the bullet was still nothing more,
and
when there were children, there will be
children in the kindergarten since Monday, no
parents leave the children at home yesterday it was
decided to close the kindergarten altogether
and not even accept those who really
need
employees are also  at home
as a result of the shelling of the place happiness
love of the sounding of the projectile the transformer of the
thermal power station on the crap of the transformer is developing
from further away and the meadows are hollow I am behind the groza
jam of the neighboring transformer this
little you can’t get down to the wall
thinner because thousands of people pass by Yar Jim